so bill ackman
billionaire made another massive bet on
the new covet 19
surge i hope we lose money on the next
hedge ackman told the financial times
conference on tuesday
we're in a treacherous time generally
and what's fascinating is the same bet
we put on eight months ago
is available on the same is available on
the same uh
terms as if there had never been a fire
and a depart
on the probability that the world is
going to be fine bill ackman just placed
another big bet against the credit
markets as coronavirus cases surge
nationwide
the billionaire has invest has said he
bought eight million dollars worth of
insurance that will pay off
if company starts defaulting on their
debts like they did
when the coronavirus shut down the
economy in the spring the bet is nearly
identical
his now famous hedge in late march in
which he turned he bought
27 million dollars of credit default
swap cds which is what they used to do
in
the movie the big short right he bought
a 27 million credit default swap
that netted him a staggering you ready
he bought 27 million dollars
in march that turned it into 2.6 billion
dollars
is what he did he's banking on the
economy taking a hit
when ackman took his profits on march
23rd there were just over 10 000 new
cases of covet 19 nationwide
on tuesday new cases were just shy of
140 000 a dizzying number that has
stoked fears of a second lockdown what
are your thoughts on this his biggest
thing was
you know he came out in mid-march
pre-lockdown i mean what was the big
event that happened that the world was
like or america was like holy what's
going on
the nba lock west or nba nba and when
the nba shut down everyone's like what
the hell's going on here that was like i
think march
yeah that was the whole maybe give or
take
fair enough yeah that's he came out i
want to say march 15
16 17 right like second week in march
and he basically is
the first thing he said is hell is
coming it was like the lead story on
cnbc
uh hedge fund billionaire bill ackman
has announced hell is coming
and basically called on trump for a
lockdown this is pre-full-on lockdown
and the dominoes fell and and clearly
the guy was right because
kovit exploded at that point he placed
the the correct bet
is has been called the what the single
best trade of all time i mean this is
what a hedge fund guy does right i mean
you buy 167 million into 2.6 billion
that
quickly that's insane do you think
there's something
shady going on there no i'm not i'm just
thinking it's a great move you know yeah
yeah he's better i saw something coming
obviously here's the deal i mean
stay in your lane though bro i mean you
know you don't need to be telling the
president what to shut down okay if you
want to get rich
you're an opportunist you're brilliant i
have no problem with that whatsoever
here's here's the problem i have he his
quote after this latest
round of shorting he goes i hope we lose
money yeah right
okay don't be disingenuous about it i
mean you're in it to make
money if you're so concerned about hey i
don't want this virus to take off and
more people to die and get sick and blah
blah blah then donate the money you made
the first time
okay you're a capitalist you want to
make the money you got the opportunity
say i hope we make another three billion
don't be like this okay it makes it he's
playing both sides he wants to be nice
but also make a couple bills protecting
himself yeah you know what i also i also
don't like the fear that he's thrown out
there too oh it's coming it's coming
back in march when he made that first
bet
there was only ten thousand cases are
there more than that now
has it gone up i haven't seen the latest
stats are there still ten thousand
no i'm joking it's like you know
wonderful millions right um
so anyway the you know it's going to
work the timing for him is perfect if
biden holds on to this
it's it's all setting up for him what
did he bet this time he put on how much
to some eight million
is that all he did so he didn't go 27
million again
correct i don't know okay this one is 30
percent as big as the last one i think
yeah 30 percent eight million yeah
exactly what are you doing just if
you're you
just put another 27 if 27 turned into
two points he's not as confident
yeah that so that eight million if it
did the same thing it would turn into
800 million dollars
that's what it would do that eight
million to 800 800 100 x your money
in the span of a couple months for the
year we already hundred x's money the
first time around
imagine going doing that again in the
space but i tell you i think if he's
going from 27 to 8 i don't think he's as
confident about the fact that he
uh it's going to be as bad if you're
that confident you would put 54.
you would put 100. what's up you just
made 2.6 billion once you put 100 of it
who cares what's 100.
you know here's my biggest problem with
it though because okay he's successful
doing this it's working a lot of people
have seen the big short movie
there's gonna be a lot of people jealous
that dave didn't think of this that have
the ability to do it that are in the
financial world
what's to stop them from creating a
frenzy that another wave is coming so
they can make a billion dollars because
the media will run with it
they love these stories that the country
has fallen apart is ready to shut down
again that the covet virus is taking
over everything so
watch for that because there's gonna be
a lot of people that are jealous they
didn't think of it
if you're watching this what do you
think about it what do you think about a
guy betting 27 million bucks to turn
into
2.6 billion dollars right afterwards
what are your thoughts is that okay are
you comfortable with that i'm curious if
you're watching this
comment below
you